[Music]
when i first saw star wars as a kid i
was blown away by the size of the death
star i mean
it was an entire man-made move
that's not a moon it's a space station
more recently however i learned how big
that star really is
this is a yoga ball and if earth was
scaled down to the size of this the
death star would be as big as an
airsoft bb this is the destroyer of
worlds
we never get to see any star wars
spaceships in any sort of physical
context because they're always next to
like planets or in outer space or next
to arbitrary sci-fi cities so that got
me wondering what they would look like
if i put them in places you're familiar
with so in today's video that's exactly
what i'm gonna do with the goal of
helping you understand
just how big these spaceships from star
wars really are
it's actually kind of crazy how many
iconic ship designs emerged from the
star wars universe
ah the millennium falcon it's about as
long as a boeing 737 and stretches three
times further than a city bus
if this thing was parked on a highway it
would take up seven lanes of traffic
talk about a traffic jam
thanks han and the imperial at-at which
honestly i don't really have much to say
other than i just wanted to
render it on our street hey enough of
them small fries let's get to some big
ships the imperial star destroyer is
1600 meters long which coincidentally
is the same length as a mile so funny
enough it actually doubles as a pretty
good unit of distance here in america
it's also interesting to see it next to
the tallest building in the world in
dubai
it's like a giant mild tall skyscraper
which actually gives me an idea for a
future video so uh hit that notification
bell for that
for our next ship though we're gonna
have to dip into the prequels a little
[Music]
bit
the trade federation battle station you
remember it that ship that looks like
someone took a bite out of a donut and
then spat it back out into the middle
[Music]
i mean come on it doesn't look like it
though this battle station is over three
kilometers in diameter making the
imperial star destroyer basically the
radius of it like the hands of a clock
and of course anakin saw that ship as a
kid and was like meh someday i'm gonna
have a ship that is 19
000 meters long and he was right a
superstar destroyer called the executor
ended up becoming darth vader's flagship
vehicle that was indeed 19 kilometers
long
it was 12 times longer than those wimpy
little star destroyers what are those
starships for ants
i say it was longer because if you've
seen return of the jetty you'll know
that it crashed into the death star like
a freaking lawn dart but alright i know
you've been waiting for it
the death stars how big were they well
the first one was 120 kilometers wide
which is legit pretty dang huge but as
i've said it's just like nothing
in comparison to an actual planet oh and
the last jetty actually introduced a
massive beast of a starship that was
snoke's flagship vehicle
this thing was 60 kilometers wide so
literally
snoke ship could be the radius of the
death star
what is up with star wars and their
obsession with making ships that could
be radii
of other ships and hey at least it had
the coolest death of any star wars ship
ever
[Music]
and that brings us to the second death
star the one that never completed
construction
according to canon it is 160 kilometers
wide which is 33
larger than the first station i always
thought it was the same size as the
first one but no apparently it's bigger
however remember that lawn dart scene
the problem is that you should be able
to clearly see the curvature of the
death star
the lack of curvature actually indicates
that it's about 900 kilometers in
diameter
which is massive it's so big
however i need more examples than just
one to really convince me that it is
larger so i'm going to stick with the
officially stated size
and the biggest on our list is the
starkiller base from the force awakens
because it is 660
kilometers wide making it the largest
station in all of star wars
according according to canon i always
thought of it as an actual planet that
was simply repurposed into a star
sucking
weapon instead we're left with something
that takes up 34 times less volume
than our own moon maybe we should
actually be complimenting the first
order on their ways of making efficient
weapons but like for real though that
thing destroyed like five planets and a
star
and the thing i found most surprising
from making this video is that all the
smaller ships like the big
smaller ships they seem massive and yet
the ones that actually are massive seem
kind of quaint
anyway this video gave me a whole new
perspective on the universe and i hope
it did for you too
in fact if you know anyone who could
also use this new perspective consider
sending this video to them and
thanks for watching i hope my name
pronunciation
didn't trigger you too much
[Applause]
me